"The Goalie’s Anxiety
at the Penalty Kick"
was really my first film.
And to fly with it to New York
and present it at the MoMA
do my very first interviews
in English
and stay in New York
for the very first time,
that was...
unbelievable.
I think I was here
for four days.
I don’t think I slept
for one second.
It had a short life
that film, because...
I had put
all the music I loved into it.
And you see
I was quite naïve and made it
for German theatrical use,
and television in Germany.
So all the music rights
I had only acquired for Germany
and theatre
for a number of years.
I didn’t think the film was...
Nobody thought
films had a longer life.
So I acquired Elvis
and Roy Orbison,
Van Morrison
and Creedence Clearwater
for just a couple of years.
And after that the film
was practically dead.
It had a glorious time
in New York
and was shown for a while.
It even got distribution later on.
But then we had
to stop it, because...
to reacquire all those rights
for international territories
would have cost
more than the entire film.
So it is only now, 40 years later,
that we freed the film again.
I had always produced
my films myself
so I always owned them,
which is of course great,
you can control them.
But the drawback is that...
anything you own
you can also lose.
And in 2000 I actually lost
possession of my entire work.
Long, sad story.
Then for ten years,
I watched the movies
that were still distributed
but they were owned
by big commercial companies.
These commercial entities are not
so much interested in restoration.
Because that means to invest
and they rather exploit it.
And then after ten years, finally...
my wife and I,
we had the cool idea
not to buy it back
because I wasn’t so interested
in personally owning
my work again.
That had gone wrong
already twice.
I don’t think it’s an ideal form
for movies to survive
to be owned by somebody.
I think it’s better
if they own themselves.
And the only form
that allows work
to own itself is a foundation.
So it took us two years to...
collect all that money,
with the foundation to acquire
each and every movie back.
Now they’re all
owned by the foundation,
and the foundation
so far has already restored eight.
When you get into restoration
and you really...
realize it’s a whole craft
and you realize
the mistakes you can do
you can over-restore it,
so all of a sudden
it looks as if it was shot today
and it was digital
and that of course
is not what we wanted.
So the basic idea
was to make it look
as good as it could
have looked in the first print.
So any hairs in the gate
that were in the first print
I left them in
because I figured...
well, we could take them out
but in that first print
they were there.
So we kept all the grain,
we stabilized the image a little bit
because the 16mm image...
always jumps a little bit,
especially every cut.
So we stabilized it.
I thought that was...
an improvement
that was pleasant for the eye.
And every scratch and stuff...
of course we did
our best to take it out.
But on the other hand,
we still liked to give it that...
film look, not work against it,
what really bring it out
as good as possible.
Scanned it in 4K but as it’s 16,
we finished it in 2K
because there’s not
more information on it.
And I think it now looks
as good as it can possibly look.
It was a great pleasure
to see it reanimated.
Our inspiration
was Walker Evans, strictly,
and we looked at
a lot of his stuff.
Our inspiration wasn’t
any other black and white films
but strictly photography.
Framing-wise, but also aesthetics.
Whenever I found anything
in corrugated iron,
we stopped and shot.
Because I thought that was
the coolest thing in black and white.
And of course for Alice,
that was the first time I was
actually able to shoot in America.
It was quite an improvised shoot,
we were a tiny little crew.
And I wanted to start it
somewhere in the South
and we didn’t really have the money
to go all the way to Florida.
So we traveled down and I said,
“When we see the first palm trees,
we’ll start shooting.”
And that became North Carolina.
So for some reason it starts
in Surf City, North Carolina.
It was also
the first road movie that I shot.
That little film
"Alice in the Cities" was...
a way for me to discover
that there was a genre
where I could feel
like a fish in the water.
It was very liberating
to shoot with such a little crew,
and direct sound...
And on the road traveling,
and stopping wherever
I saw something that I liked
and we invent the scene there.
Did you take a lot
of still photographs on that trip?
I was still
a Polaroid photographer.
And "Alice in the Cities"
of course is the film
where people saw for the first time
the I-670 land camera.
We got a prototype from them.
And even when the film came out
most people had never seen
this camera where...
the picture came out,
and then you saw nothing
and slowly it would develop
in front of your eyes.
So that was
the big fetish of the film.
But you were interested
in Polaroids before that.
What drew you
to Polaroids as opposed to Leicas
or printing in a darkroom?
I loved the idea
that they only existed one.
I liked the idea that...
you took a picture
and it only existed once.
Of course you could make copies
but I never did, and I liked
the idea that it was...
You took it once
and it existed once,
and it was just
one piece that was...
entirely related
to that second that you took it.
There was
so much truth about the act,
and there is nothing
phony about a Polaroid.
Because you can’t fake anything.
You can’t interfere
with the process.
And once it’s there, that’s
what it is, that’s all you get.
I really liked that;
for years, I didn’t do anything else.
Later on, I went
to a larger form and negatives,
and took photography
more seriously.
But at the time,
that was the first camera
you could actually do selfies with.
The first camera you can
really be very spontaneous.
Also give those pictures away,
sometimes people
just didn’t know...
you could do something
and then hand it over to them
and say, “Keep it.”